a new day a new crime scene last night
here in East London a fifteen-year-old
was stabbed to death with a knife social
worker Paul McKenzie has visited many
such crime scenes but this time it
really gets to him the victim was a
friend the va's nephew it's just
happening too much isn't it did you see
these these are everywhere you used to
see a bunch of flowers years ago and it
meant something you really sort of went
over there and read the request now it's
just like it's too many to read more
than likely only because somebody wanted
to prove something to somebody else
that's that's the sad thing that a life
has become a point system and now
somebody's some ways say me you know
they know who did that and and that
person gets respect often it's a case of
rivalry between members of youth gangs
but innocent bystanders can also fall
victim to knife crime in some gangs
knifing someone is proof a youngster is
worthy of belonging to a gang
thirteen years old being arrested for
knifeman robbery whatever what happened
Mackenzie talks the gang members and
makes videos to show how quickly things
are deteriorating in some parts of
London why do you carry a 15 inch knife
he's big and you get them scared
what's a few safe because I don't want
someone put it off with me let Jenna
Jenna kill me so I'll kill him I don't
want to die Paul McKenzie feels that the
government doesn't take the knife crime
seriously enough he supports an
initiative which demands that the
government treat the violence as a
national emergency
I've lost my younger brother the
moisture to knife crime this was my son
Isaiah he was more murdered in 2015 I
lost my son on the 30th of September
2017 my step nephew he died free night
crime and the 5th of February this year
I was knife through the heart in some
neighborhoods young people don't leave
home without a knife as they think they
must be prepared to defend themselves
McKenzie says that the scum that combat
knives are sold freely that Rambo knife
in particular is is the favorite knife
at the moment then it says collect for
Rambo knives and you get a discount you
can see all sorts of different types of
knives in a window and for me it's not
something you want to advertise in a
window especially with what's going on
moment Jason Isaacs was stabbed to death
one and a half years ago he was sharing
Kendall's eldest son now her younger
children always have to come home
straight from school because she fears
for their lives
Jason was killed early in the evening
while he was out with a few friends
Jason was with four friends was five of
them and yeah that's the one for their
lives and they all went in different
directions and Jason got caught and was
stabbed eight times
Jason was targeted by a gang which he
himself had nothing to do with everyone
that knew Jess and he always hooked you
and kissed him which was nice because
every every time he went out off he did
collide he's I was a love your mom our
case and that's what we got that night
and we did everything together really we
he was a very family person Jason's
killer was caught he was just 17 at the
time rap videos of him and his gang
could be seen on the Internet known as
drill this style of hip-hop is very
popular with British youths
they talk about stabbing people in the
back which is what they do
and Jessen obviously was stabbed in his
back in his back sir
and then the boy ended up dead what
influence does drill music and what can
you do when carrying a knife is
considered normal these are the kinds of
questions Paul McKenzie asks in his
talks with teens everyone here is
familiar with drill they all know kids
who carry knives finding answers it's
tough but these youths and their parents
agree jail time isn't enough I know
someone that's in prison and like he's
still able to get a phone and post on
snapchat that he's in dream prison
they're just listening to music rap in
didn't all it out so prison isn't really
like a big thing to them the issue here
is a systemic one violence is normalized
now unless we start looking a bit
further above the young people we're
never gonna get to the bottom of this
then he values any new belief systems
they need to believe there is a future
you talk to some of these young people
they can't see past 20 and any society
that has a generation of young people
that can't see past 20
you've got it you've gotta address that
from above
Paul McKenzie knows there aren't any
quick fixes to this situation the
British government is now committed
itself to investing in youth work and
strengthening the police presence
everyone knows the problem has simply
become too large to ignore